at an early voting location in Las Vegas
people waited in line for over an hour
to cast their ballots first volunteers
help the voters enter their names and
addresses into tablets next voters fill
out their preferences for the Democratic
nomination on a paper form finally the
secret paper ballot is checked then
dropped into a ballot box results will
be tabulated on computer spreadsheets
and sent by a Wi-Fi link to party
precincts and state headquarters for
most voters the process went smoothly it
was relatively easy to understand I mean
just a kind of a pain to come out here
and you know do that but I think it's
something that's necessary a flawed
smartphone app and a failed
communication system led to this
spectacular breakdown of the Iowa
caucuses something Nevada is anxious not
to repeat the Nevada Democratic Party
ditched the app but election experts say
the caucuses will use some new
technologies without providing adequate
training what we hear from leaks coming
out of those training sessions is that
it's fairly chaotic the technology
solution should have been fully baked
and finished at least a couple of months
ago volunteer and community organizer
Huey new in says the system is working
well so far we double-checking and
triple-checking to make sure that the
data all the same on paper and on a
tablet caucus volunteers and experts
here say the decision to have early
voting was key taking off much of the
pressure to count all the votes at once
and help avoid an Iowa style caucus melt
down the question is can they integrate
the early voting into the precinct
voting that's gonna happen on Saturday
and do that seamlessly I'm not saying
there will not be in issues but at least
it won't hold up the entire world that's
good because the world wants to know how
Nevada will shape the Democratic race
and ultimately the election in November
and it wants to know fast Rob Reynolds
al-jazeera Las Vegas